et voilà
ça alors je ne comprends pas le lot sont
les biens plat et ma table et ben kahla
comment vous savez pourquoi ma table
bancale
que je suis bête évidemment j'ai mon
pied gauche sous son pied droit
merci
bon j'attends le le facteur il doit
m'apporter un délicieux gâteau que m'a
préparé ma tante adélaïde j'espère qu'il
ne va pas tarder
casimir ne vois-tu rien venir je vois la
route qui poudroie mais pas de facteur à
l'horizon j'espère qu'il n'est pas en
train de manger mon gâteau casimir à
casimir voilà ton colis je voudrais
arrêter un patient chacun
sait que tu me connais un les colis et
le courrier toujours à premier à votre
avis le formuler tous et tous bords et
ben tu le vois pas il ya je vais
l'ouvrir oui ben ghazi lavage je
l'ouvrirai et tu veux que je louvre
alémanique
ou
alors un duel magnifique gâteau n est ce
pas bon et où des facteurs sur scène
vous êtes très pressés alors je ne vous
retient pas ah non non non non non je ne
suis pas du tout pressé japon j'ai fini
ma tournée
enfin pourquoi avez vous apporté une
chaise
j'ai pensé que tu m'as éviterait un
enjeu le gâteau mais ce n'est pas tout
cas j'ai apporté également une assiette
et puis une petite fourchette à gâteau
mais enfin comment saviez-vous que
c'était un gâteau au c'est facile sur le
carton c'est écrit fragile cats au japon
bon ben je vais le coup tu es un bon je
vais le couper en deux la moyens de
chacun 1 et en plus ils en veulent à
moitié
je suis bien contente j'arrive à caen
j'avais peur d'être en retard de trois
mois aussi tu savais que j'attendais un
gâteau je pense que le facteur a passé
son temps dans sa tournée a crié
kazimiyah temps et gâteaux mabon grave
est un tout petit morceau est un tout
petit morceau tout le koup 1,3 à thiers
chaque attendez moi c'est pas tant
d'émoi tant d'étoilés
hambourg on voulait manger le gâteau en
suisse mais pourquoi en suisse en vain
nous sommes sur l'île aux enfants les
émirs en suisse ça veut dire tout seul
sans rien dire aux autres mais nous
parle de cloud françois goethe
attendaient avec impatience
alors nous sommes
deux trois quatre jeux coûtent donc le
gâteau en quatre pour les quarts chaque
tête et espoir parce qu'il ne manquerait
plus que monsieur du snug alors qu à
bonchamp m'est très cher ça me
[Musique]
demande pas si vous voulez du gâteau
alors nous sommes donc un deux trois
quatre cinq on va donc le couper en
abondance loyaux à oui biensur castro
fait je t'apporte est une loupe casimir
je vous remercie mais moi je marche avec
une une fourchette annoncée c'est pas
pour manger c'est simplement pour
regarder ton cinquième morceau vous êtes
aura l'impression qu'il est cinq fois
plus
[Rires]
écouté puisque nous sommes tous réunis
je coupe le gâteau en scène d'accord il
a l'air
moi j'en ai l'eau à la bouche alors qu
il est au jeu et bien il s'agit d'un
mélange arbres il y a donc dû chocolat
de la vanille et du sucre de l'huile de
foie de morue
de la moutarde d'art et
d'essai ce 4 août
et du poivre vert
enfin ça l'a alors
allo tante adélaïde un oui comment un
gâteau tout simple au chocolat
c'est tout ah bon bon d'accord pour voir
mr quelle horreur alors un simple gâteau
au chocolat j'ai horreur de ça
les enfants vous voulez du gâteau venez
entrez entrez un star iv est ce que vous
aimez le gâteau au chocolat et à
l'avenir
bon alors écoutez servez vous régalez
vous bon appétit
tante adélaïde aaa
[Musique]